you need to be better a lot of people
write in to me and they say Evan I've
got a great product I've got a great
service I'm fantastic at what I do but
I'm not getting the momentum I need
because because I don't have the dollars
I don't have the resources I don't have
the marketing I don't have the skills
the communication skills to do it and
what I would challenge you to think
about is forget about that stuff forget
about the resources you don't have are
you actually really great at what you do
are you one of the best in the world at
what you do or do you just think you're
great because there's a huge difference
and if you want to have tremendous
success and you need to be one of the
best in the world at what you do and you
need to go home and practice and work
harder and get better and be innovative
to really stand out your talent should
be obvious when people meet you your
talent should be obvious you'd be
screaming off the page this person is
really good if that's not happening then
you need to get better I want to share a
clip of Eminem who called into a radio
station he crank called they said it was
Jason from Miami his mentor his Idol LL
Cool J's on the show and they have no
idea who he is he says he's Jason from
Miami and he's calling in he's rapping
is doing is saying he's doing what he's
really good at which is rapping and they
have no idea who he is but they're
saying dude you got talent and if he
called in to a couple of other shows
people would spot his talent and he
would get picked up quickly because he
was really really good at what he did he
put the work in to become better so if
you want to get spotted if you want
people to notice you if you want to
build momentum around your business stop
blaming the lack of resources that you
have stop blaming other people for not
talking about you look in the mirror and
get better at the product and service
and skills that you're putting out there
I think you'll enjoy this clip
we got hello Cool J I really need my
real friends out there to call up maybe
I ll is here miss amazing your shake 45
you on their caller who's this hello
yo this is Jason man all right J we come
from I'm calling from Miami what's up
baby yeah I just you know I've been a
die-hard ll fan you know since since the
first album and I just want to know if I
can play like a low name that tune kind
of thing where ll you know if I like rap
some his lyrics and see if you know if
he can get on there from oh man
boy you I don't know if I'm gonna be
able to do it try it go ahead I try I
play with I play the game with you got
all right check it out bring on the
Mosin [ __ ] eat him up l chill yeah
that's cute a mother hold your nose dead
bodies all around all these scratch
marks under the tears of a clown I write
Rhymes that shine like lipstick so much
material but not materialistic imperial
styles use yo that was crazy that's eat
them up eat him up l yeah that was crazy
all right
yeah that's crazy I got one more for you
all right let's do it
the president won't gonna call the
Parthenon the Golden Globe yes alone to
raise Michelangelo from the dead so we
can make a fresh painting on my head
yeah that was my bra made up of the
second album damn yeah I got one more I
got one more alright three years ago in
Saint Albans Queens I was rocking in a
park called 118 little kids stood and
watched us I rock the spot didn't know
years later I'll be standing on top we
were farmers Boulevard I was born in
patient
snob the rich and shake hands with the
poor and missus the story about a
brother I know
co-creator on a fader now watch him go
yeah yeah let's go co-creator go yeah I
can't believe you ain't you sound good
Satyam Joyce like it so hot like I'm
knocked out of city is like front but yo
yourself hot saying the Joyce like yeah
beat that sound like you need it right
some balls homie where you do sound good
man you're what you call it for men
who's this man did differ Jason from
Miami man yo ass out yo sound good baby
and definitely you know you brought back
a lot of memories with those songs many
good looking at you one love Jason I got
I got a song I wrote myself can I can I
drop a little something well yeah yeah
that's it again is he your joint I
called it this is what I wrote myself
his palms are sweaty knees weak arms are
heavy design all right there I love it
ladies and gentlemen Marshall Mathers on
the phone singing boys say 45 ha ha
what's up baby how you met yo man
everything is beautiful man you say I'm
good on their bed yeah everything's good
and I've been a fan forever like
honestly I've been a fan forever I know
we really had a chance to like you know
meet me I know we met like one time in
the footlocker yeah and uh you know that
was crazy to me because I had just
jumped on board with Dre mm-hmm you know
so it was you know I was a little bit
you know I was a little bit starstruck
you know yeah you know I I had to be
with you you know so man is it is crazy